Sebastian pinera is already presidents.
Well,
actually he's president again because as
you all know,
this political leader was president of
Chile,
barely two mandates ago,
between 2010 and 2014
Tina
now after achieving a strong and healthy
victory by almost 10 points in the 2017
presidential elections to and pin yarrow
was declared president on March the
11th.
They have you in this video today,
we are going to be seeing what kinds of
chili this president is inheriting as
well as the greatest challenges that lie
ahead for him,
but first of all,
let's get to know this character better.
Let's see who Sebastian Pinera really
is.
Yes.
Is Sebastian Kenyatta?
We need to know that Sebastian Pinera
for many reasons,
isn't just another politician we use.
We're talking about a man who on the one
hand zones,
one of the biggest fortunes in Chile for
Fortune Forbes magazine estimates.
There's no less than two point
$7,000,000,000.
Yep.
You heard that right?
You'll see them.
They'll go,
yet nobody's suitable.
Keep the feet on the politicals.
He lost the wound book.
I know.
Yes.
Sebastian Pinera was an aggressive,
self-made businessmen,
but do not be fooled by his smile.
His record shows that for a long time
knew how to play to the limit and it's
become a major investor in various
sectors such as construction,
supermarkets,
airlines,
and TV channels.
Now that I think about it,
it's really hard to find a sexier in
which pin Yaarit didn't try his luck.
Even in 2006,
he decided to death on the football
industry and took control of a team,
but not just any team.
Nope.
He took control of the most important
soccer team in Chile.
Color color.
Of course.
Many critics accuse him of buying this
team north as an investment spot,
as a political maneuver like Silvio
Berlusconi,
but don't think that Pinera is exploit,
swell only in the business exit.
Not at all.
In fact,
the political arena,
the current president of Chile also left
his mark in 2010,
he became the first right wing
presidents to be democratically elected
since 1958.
He also became the first right wing
president since Chile underwent its
democratic transition after a Gusto
Pinochet's Yep.
Now in 2018,
this is happening again.
In other words,
we could say that Sebastien Vignette
road is a pretty fortunate guy and I
don't think he'd disagree.
Well,
the fact is that in his first term,
despite having to face the consequences
of a terrible earthquake that shook his
country just two weeks before he took
office,
his first governments had relatively
good results,
at least half of our efforts throughout
the entire administration were devoted
to rebuilding the country,
and consequently we had to sacrifice
many things.
We wanted to do Rodrigo Hinzpeter,
minister of the interior and Minister of
defense in Sebastian Pianos for
government.
The truth is that no great revolutionary
change really happens.
However,
in his first four years of government in
the economy grew by more than five
percent per year,
more than 1 million jobs were created,
wages increased,
poverty fell sharply.
We had a really good government in which
every social and economic indicator
improved in Chile,
but I have more experience now and
experience counts,
Sebastian Miata.
And the truth is the viewer.
In this case,
all that experience can be really,
really important.
And why is this?
Well,
because today chili is really quite
different.
I mean,
pay attention to this.
Today's Chili.
Yeah.
He told you here on visual politic
previously,
and I don't think it will surprise
anyone,
but in the last few decades,
Chile has been something like Latin
America's Christiana,
Ronaldo,
the country that grew the most,
the one that had the most success,
convincing proof of this was the
evolution of the Chilean middle class,
which multiplies by almost three within
a very short span of time.
The Chilean Middleclass grew from 23
point seven percent to 64 point three
percent of the population in 25 years.
However,
as we saw in a previous video in recent
years,
specifically during Micell Bash,
allays last term,
things really changed.
Wished you let them sooner.
Yeah.
As we mentioned in recent years,
economic growth has plummeted.
Job Creation has slowed,
wages haven't grown,
and foreign investment has dropped.
Lately.
The only thing that has grown in Chile
has been the number of public employees,
taxes and bureaucracy.
That's right.
Practically every economic parameters
made a very negative change during the
child.
Ashley's last time.
I mean,
check this out,
there has been an average growth of
belly one point eight percent per year,
which implies that this legislation was
the worst economic growth since the
democratic trends
session.
In fact,
in recent years she has grown,
uh,
less than the world economy and it's
considerably less than it's specific
alliance counterparts,
Mexico,
Peru,
and Colombia.
And that's not all the public deficit
when from being a guest to a permanent
tenants.
And of course that's certainly has
consequences.
Public debt,
although still low,
has reached its highest level since
1993.
Having the fiscal debt double every four
years isn't sustainable.
That's the road to the precipice for
leap.
Lorraine,
Minister of finance,
although by far the worst development
has been the four year consecutive drop
in investments and it wasn't only the
economy that went.
South crime rates have increased a lot
in the near region where there's a
conflict with the indigenous people.
The mapuches who demands more autonomy
and recognition.
Violent acts have exploded growing by a
hundred and 50 percent.
And even regarding the government's
decision to suspend the hospital
concession system has meant that the
government has barely been able to
invest more than half of what they'd
budgeted,
making wait lists and quality issues,
a chronic problem,
and let's not deceive ourselves here as
always,
the ones most effected by all of this
are not the richest,
but the middle class,
and even more so for the most vulnerable
people in the population,
the poor people.
In other words,
it's fair to say the Chileans have new
reason to celebrate me,
how Basha lays last time.
Indeed,
they were an incredibly intense four
years.
Now perhaps we could analyze what's
happening in Chile by taking a look at
their economic freedom index,
who's correlation with a country's level
of wealth and prosperity is very high.
Well,
during the calabash relays,
last term,
eat felt from seventh position too.
Yeah.
Anyway,
this is the situation that the new
president of Chile has to face.
And now the question we need to ask
ourselves is,
what should this new government's
priorities be?
What can we expect?
What should we expect from them?
Well,
let's take a look.
That's the name of it.
If you're not getting it a little bit,
great challenges.
Well,
it seems quite clear.
There's in a country that isn't exactly
cheap and in which three out of four
workers make less than $800 a month,
the economy has to be then number one
priority.
If the economy isn't doing well,
social statistics do well either,
and this seems to be very,
very clear for the new government.
In fact,
Pinera,
the new president has promised to focus
his efforts on doubling economic growth.
Creating hundreds of jobs sends laying
the foundations for Chile to become the
first developed country in Latin America
by 2025,
but of course you might be thinking,
well,
how on earth can they achieve this?
I hope he doesn't think that a mere tax
reform is going to be enough to restore
Chili's.
Growth is going to need an aggressive
policy to stimulate diversification.
Almost half of the country's exports are
still copper.
Ricardo Hausmann.
Well,
to achieve the 20,
25 goal,
the country needs to deal with three
very clear priorities,
diversifying their economy,
improve their productivity,
and adjust their public accounts.
But do not think that this is an easy
task to diversify the economy,
to stop relying on raw materials,
especially copper and boost their
productivity.
Then near is Chile will need a few
things.
First,
they will need to promote investment,
especially foreign investments that is
attract more companies and foreign
capital who will bet on Shelly to
produce and provide services.
Ms Dot lamb could really be helped by a
reversal of bash delays,
terrible tax reform,
which not only raised taxes on
companies,
but also punished that investments.
This was really not a good idea.
Further,
they should decrease the huge
bureaucracy that exists.
For example,
by digitizing every possible process.
Seconds,
and this is a much more controversial
issue for this Latin American country.
They need to promote a program to
attract foreign talents.
Yeah,
they really need to be promoting
immigration.
You see,
in Chile,
the immigrant population has grown a lot
in recent years,
but it's still very low.
It hasn't even reached three percent of
the population and she lands like to
compare themselves with Australia and
New Zealand were immigrants make up 30
percent of the total population.
10 Times more than they do in Chile.
Yes,
you really did hear that right,
and the best way to gain talents and
promote different businesses and
activities is to attract people with
different skills and abilities from all
over the world.
We're actually going to be discussing
that in more detail really soon,
but for now,
here's a great example.
In Silicon Valley,
the great global innovation center,
Fifty four percent of entrepreneurs are
foreign.
Yeah,
we're not talking about an open door,
but we are talking about setting up a
mechanism that clarifies and promotes
talent attraction because,
well,
the end of the day,
if it all goes well,
surely you can aspire to become the
great benchmark for business in Latin
America.
And that implies attracting
professionals.
In addition,
and this is an important detail,
according to all Chilean standards,
immigrants have more education on
average that Labor participation is much
higher and they even though
money
policies eat,
needs to enforce improving relations
between universities and companies
fighting insecurity and ending the
public deficits as well as improving
infrastructure and increasing savings.
So now if we take a look at the program,
we will see that the president's
promises seem to align with this,
so in principle has been as good change
is going to be really good for Chile.
Now,
of course,
as always,
only time will tell,
but just hold on a moment because not
everything is quite so simple.
See,
due to an electoral reform that a
promoted pin Jerez coalition doesn't
have a majority in Congress,
so negotiating and seeking parliamentary
agreements will be a priority for this
new governmental team.
So Dev you are.
That's the way things are in Chile
today,
but now it's your turn.
What's your opinion on Sebastian Pinera
is new governments.
Do you think his government will be good
for Chile?
Well,
leave your answer in the comment section
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoy this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and do not forget to subscribe
because we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't mine,
and as always,
thanks for watching
and Emma Catherine.